[Music]
hi I'm Ike same ol from FX guide.com
for wide since the debut of Jurassic
Park 20 years ago how understanding of
dinosaurs has changed exponentially what
was hinted at back then in terms of
links to birds is now accepted
scientific doctrine in literally half of
all the dinosaurs we know about have
been discovered in the last 20 years so
in 2012 for example that met they'll
been discovered a rate of about one a
week you jump to today the animation
company animal logic were tasked with
producing a new breed of more accurate
dinosaurs for the new Walking with
Dinosaurs feature film set in an epic
prehistoric kind of world this is a
family film not a documentary but still
the filmmakers insisted on not
anthropomorphizing the creatures and
making them as accurate as they possibly
could this film is one of the first
movies for example to actually depict
many of the dinosaur characters with
seiya feathery codes such as the trade
on animal logic luckily had already
developed a complex feather system for
legends of the guardians hours of the
girl hall the existing custom feather
grooming tool is named quilt animal
logic added to this two new pieces of
technology called steroid and reptile
the first is a new muscle simulation
system in the past the system had to
work with various muscle groups each
kind of triggered with various paces or
types of animation like a walk or a run
that required a lot of tweaking and
adjustment per scene in this film
they're dealing with some very muscular
creatures like the Gorgosaurus so all
the muscles needed to be controlled by
one system and not require kind of
individual tweaking the second system is
a procedural scales and physically
plausible shading system for the skin
and texture of the animals it's called
reptile this allows for complex
procedural generation avoiding having to
hand paint and texture thousands of
scales per creature the new system
allows for these rigid blocks to sit on
top of a movable skin layer which
expands and contracts under the scales
it automatically provides a unique rigid
scale to sort of sit down flat and not
bend or
even though the skin underneath it does
so all of this helps place the animated
characters more accurately in their
real-world environments and our
understanding continues to change a
surprising rate even since the film
started production three years ago new
facts of emerge that are now requiring
us to rethink what a dinosaur is and
especially what it looks like
well don't forget to subscribe for more
behind-the-scenes action I'm Ike Cemal
for wide
[Music]